el miércoles por la tarde despegó la
nave soyuz ms-22 en kazajistán un raro
ejemplo reciente de cooperación entre
Washington y Moscú el lanzamiento supuso
la reanudación de la participación de
Estados Unidos en los vuelos a la
estación espacial internacional tras un
año de pausa
la NASA había interrumpido la
cooperación con la agencia espacial rusa
luego de la invasión aucrania y reanudó
los vínculos en julio El astronauta
estadounidense Frank Rubio se unió a sus
colegas rusos los cosmonautas sergey
procopief y Dimitri petrelin a bordo de
la soyuz en la expedición 68
a pesar de las tensiones políticas
existentes dicen que no han tenido
problemas para cooperar
Francia integró muy bien con nuestra
tripulación con nuestro equipo ahora
trabajamos en la misma sintonía nos
entendemos a interactuamos muy bien
Tenemos un gran equipo y Tenemos un gran
equipo de instructores tanto aquí en
roscosmos como en la NASA y por eso
siento que han hecho un trabajo
absolutamente estupendo para prepararnos
y estamos deseando estar en esta misión
la tripulación se encargará el
mantenimiento de la estación y
participará en experimentos para el
módulo científico de la estación
espacial internacional la colaboración
continuará en octubre cuando la única
mujer cosmonauta activa de Rusia Ana
kikina viaja a la estación espacial a
bordo de la nave space Club dragón
construida por la empresa del
multimillonario estadounidense y los
moscco la estación espacial depende de
un sistema de propulsión ruso para
mantener su órbita Rusia pretende
abandonar la estación en 2024 para crear
su propia estación orbital